[Music]  photons are the source of light and heat  but they also caused something far more  destructive the solar wind  as they reach the surface photons heat  up the outer layers of the Sun  sending it hurtling around the star  creating extreme turbulence and intense  shock waves it's so violent we can  actually hear it picked up by the  orbiting Soho satellite this is the  sound of the Sun the speeding gases also  generate powerful magnetic fields as the  star rotates the fields clash and bursts  through the surface  giant magnetic loops erupt into space  some are so large the earth could pass  right through them with thousands of  miles to spare they are spectacular and  they are deadly blasting a stream of  electrical particles deep into space  this is the solar wind  it can damage spaceships and satellites  even put astronauts lives in jeopardy